coming as absolutely no surprise
whatsoever president Donald Trump has
been acquitted found not guilty in his
impeachment trial in the United States
Senate on both counts article one was
abusive power article two was
obstruction of Congress on that first
article 52 votes for not guilty forty
eight votes for guilty
it was a party-line vote except for Utah
Republican Mitt Romney former governor
of Massachusetts Mitt Romney crossed
party lines and voted guilty on article
one he made a speech in advance of the
vote saying he planned to do so and
explaining why on article two
obstruction of Congress a straight
party-line vote fifty three Republicans
voting not guilty forty five Democrats
and two independents Bernie Sanders and
angus King voting guilty party line vote
the outcome never in doubt we knew that
Republicans had prejudged we heard from
Mitch McConnell that he was going to be
in total coordination with the White
House on the impeachment trial and
Republicans made it a foregone
conclusion that this was ultimately
going to be the outcome we knew this
going in a bogus trial no witnesses
imagined a trial in which you complain
that you don't have firsthand witnesses
which Republicans did many times despite
having them in the form of Alexander VIN
Minh and others and when John Bolton
went public or his manuscript was leaked
or he made it get leaked whatever we
found out that he was a first-hand
witness who could come forward and
testify and say Donald Trump told me to
withhold the aid from Ukraine until such
time that they publicly smear Joe Biden
they didn't have firsthand witnesses
they wanted them one becomes available
and they vote and say we don't want
witnesses we don't need witnesses the
house could have called witnesses if
they had wanted to a completely bogus
trial almost just a formality was the
trial despite sixty four hours of
proceedings plus debate about whether to
call witnesses plus statements yesterday
from dozens of senator
before ultimately voting to acquit
Donald Trump so Donald Trump the third
president to be impeached by the house
all three of those presidents ultimately
acquitted in the Senate in the 1800s it
was Andrew Johnson in the 1900s it was
Bill Clinton and now in 2020 it is
Donald Trump so now the questions become
was this worth it what's next
and what does this do for Donald Trump
in terms of approval in terms of
November of 2020 s election we are going
to talk about all of those things Donald
Trump yesterday some Trump is gleefully
pointing out that Trump is now polling
higher than ever in the Gallup
presidential approval poll at 49% we
talked about this on the bonus show
unfortunately that lacks some context
which we will get to including the fact
that that was from before Trump's
acquittal now of course we knew that
once Trump was acquitted what we are
calling exoneration delusion would
immediately take hold as soon as the
acquittal took place and indeed indeed
it did Donald Trump immediately tweeting
quote I will be making a public
statement tomorrow at 12 p.m. from the
White House to discuss our country's
victory on the impeachment hoax you may
already by the time you watch or listen
to today's show know what it was that
Donald Trump said during that
presentation if you were surprised by
the acquittal then you simply not been
paying attention and I know that there
are lots of people who are just busy
with their lives and they don't pay
attention and that's okay and in fact
I'm sort of envious of you to a great
degree during a number of our recent
live streams I would get super chats
from people saying hey David how likely
do you think Trump gets convicted in the
Senate the answer was of course zero so
or you know 0.1 I don't know we knew all
along that it wasn't going to happen so
some in the audience when I would point
this out were mad at me and they would
say David you know you were being a
defeatist why are you calling it a
foregone conclusion we need to fight but
as I've said before I tell you things as
they are not as I would like them to be
and there is no question that it was a
sham trial I told you that from the
beginning but at the same time we have
to recognize that there is no question
that the last seven dude
72 hours have been really really bad for
Democrats just bad timing combined with
Fiasco's Monday night embarrassing
outcome in the first 2020 Democratic
primary which is the Iowa caucus the app
used to communicate results imploded we
as of this recording still don't have
final results from Iowa
Tuesday night Donald Trump does a total
reality show State of the Union address
but trumpets absolutely love it they see
Trump's idiocy as presidential the stock
market has several very good days in a
row and of course we know you know what
what what what does that mean for a
rural Trump estándar City who has no
shares of stock well it doesn't matter
if it means that their support for
Donald Trump is reinvigorated then
Tuesday yes Donald Trump's best approval
rating ever in the Gallup presidential
approval poll despite his overall
numbers not moving that much and then
yesterday Donald Trump acquitted on both
counts in impeachment we've talked
before about was this Donald Trump's
worst week ever for his presidency
this week was a very good week for
Donald Trump individually none of the
things I just mentioned are actually
exonerations or accomplishments by
Donald Trump in any real sense the Iowa
situation has nothing to do with Trump
Trump State of the Union was terrible in
practice Trump's acquittal was not an
exoneration in reality it was a
political majority having its way as we
knew they would from the beginning but
it doesn't look good for Democrats and
we need to recognize this if we want to
keep fighting this the right way and
from how does it feel perspective which
is often all that matters it is very
good for Donald Trump so now it's time
to win in November there is the question
was impeachment worth it and we pulled
our YouTube audience we got thirty five
thousand people voting in our poll was
impeaching Donald Trump worth while even
though he's getting acquitted 68% of you
said yes it was the Democrats
constitutional duty to impeach 2% said
yes
because it was politically beneficial
for Democrats very few people believing
that this was politically beneficial for
Democrats or that it will be 16% of you
said it was not worth it to impeach
because it ended up benefiting Donald
Trump politically and then eight percent
said it was not worthwhile because it
distracted from more important issues
that's a completely unscientific poll
merely of the YouTube audience that
chose to participate thirty five
thousand votes so we knew there'd be no
other path forward and now there is no
other path forward
yes we're hearing the House of
Representatives is planning to subpoena
former Trump national security advisor
John Bolton anyway to maybe get him on
the record saying under oath Trump came
to me and said withhold the Ukraine aid
if and until Ukraine smears Joe Biden
publicly trumpets won't care yes the
House of Representatives is looking at
subpoenaing left Parnas who has all
sorts of audio visual and written
recordings written records of the things
that Donald Trump was involved in and so
on and so forth trumpets are not going
to care so understand that the 2020
election as I've been saying at least
since April of 2017 is both the only way
but also the 2020 election is in serious
jeopardy and we're gonna dig into this
more later today Donald Trump now has
nine months to attempt and prepare
almost any amount of election meddling
interference and rigging that he wants
he has gotten off without any
consequences for everything so far okay
some of his associates were arrested and
found guilty and are gonna spend some
time in prison he doesn't seem to care
and it may not impact his November of
2020 re-election whatsoever he is
emboldened his followers are emboldened
so now not only do we have to win in
November we have to win by so much that
the meddling can't hand the election to
Trump that the foul play can't hand the
election to Trump and I'll get into more
detail about that later because I don't
believe Donald Trump will go peacefully
if he is defeated in November these are
potentially very dark days for our
democracy coming up and
thinking you know thinking ahead of us
these next four years could be much
darker than the first four years this is
the reality of the u.s. and 2020 the
world is laughing people who care in the
United States are not laughing but this
week by any measure it is a win for
Donald Trump in the immediate with the
only possibility lurking nine months
away being that this is so inspiring to
so many anti Trump voters that they all
get out in November and the tables turn
but it's going to require work and we've
got to do the work and we're going to
talk about that in much more detail
coming up a little bit later today